at the home of late basiru baro
a feast is being prepared by a member of
the family he left behind 25 years ago
baro and 13 others were executed by
former president yaya jamie
for allegedly planning a coup his body
like many other gambians was never
recovered
since his death baro's widow is finding
it hard
to find closure i know me personally
i know me personally i will not forgive
anybody
if they come to me i will tell them to
ask basiru for forgiveness
go to basiru the hardship i face i will
leave that to god
god will judge everything but me i
cannot forget
you shall tell the commission about the
atmosphere that emotion is shared by
others who also lost
loved ones for two and a half years
sankariyabu
and hundreds of other surviving victims
and their families
testified before a truth commission
detailing the atrocities committed by
the regime
the testimonies including those of
members of a hits court
led to the discovery of mass graves and
the grim task of assuming the remains
former teacher bat sambalo lived through
14 months of humiliating detention and
torture
that left him scout for life the worst
experience that i had was
when both hands and legs were tied but
on a wooden arm chair you cannot move
you cannot breathe
that time that place that pain was
continuous
and they will come through cold water on
your skin
and continue electrocuting you
on your body till you get scented
trrc the prince taking work of the
commission was led by former adviser to
the united
nations secretary general la minschi
says the government will have to
implement the commission's
recommendations
to help the victims to move on what's
the alternative
you do nothing 22 years of atrocities
the slaughter of
innocent civilians the witch-hunting
thing that
might led them to the death of over 30
40 people the
massive amount of torture that really is
happening in the area
that we forget about all that and then
just somehow
sweep it under the carpet and then move
on no
i don't think the government would do
that either many victims say they hope
the government will have the courage to
do that
but they won't bet on it the truth and
reconciliation commission
is expected to recommend the prosecution
of the perpetrators of serious crimes
and reparation for the victims the
government has already set aside one
million dollars
as compensation for victims with the
promise of another one million to come
gambians and activists will be watching
closely to see what the reaction of the
government of president adam obado will
be
to the recommendations of the commission
but with the gambia
preparing for a presidential election in
early december victims like sankaryabo
may have to wait a bit longer for
justice to be served on people she vowed
never to forgive
until then she will continue to bear the
burden of her anger
and the pain of losing a husband she
said meant the world to her
mohammed idris al jazeera banjo